and the man who is exposing all of this
oh he's out with a brand-new book he is
the host of the number-one show right
here on the Fox News Channel Sunday
nights the host of life liberty and
Levin and of course he has his
nationally syndicated radio show and
author right there unfreedom of the
press there's a reason I call him the
great one he's a great personal friend
my brother how are you okay bless you
bro how are you you know what I love
about your books America I mean Liberty
tyranny everything you go through such
detail historical detail you know I
before I get to these idiots that we're
playing here yeah you do remind us about
the press in the past and I remember you
told the story for example how they
treated Jefferson the brutal battle
between Quincy Adams and Hamilton I mean
that went off the the the ledge in some
ways but today is very different so my
first question is why did you want that
context in history there first of all I
want the American people to understand
that freedom of the press is there
freedom of the press it doesn't belong
to CNN it doesn't belong to MSNBC free
speech freedom of the press they're both
in the First Amendment for a reason when
this country was started it was the
pamphleteers a handful of newspaper men
the printers they were great great
Patriots and these were the men who
pushed for revolution who pushed the
ideas who talked about philosophers like
Locke and Montesquieu and so far you
would you have done in your past books
which I have in my past books but these
were the people the printing press there
were only a few of them they have moved
them from time to time because the
British were trying to find them and
hunt them down they pushed these ideas
Thomas Paine was a great pamphleteer
there were many many others and what
would happen is people would read these
pamphlets they talk about him at their
pubs at their homes at the dinner table
and word would spread common sense
Thomas Paine's pamphlet it's estimated
120,000 people read it there was a
country about 2 million people and by
the time it was over half a million
people had read it it had enormous
influence why is it important because
back then what it our
they didn't call themselves the press
but what did the press do promoted
liberty individualism representative
government private property rights low
taxes and so forth and then from that
period soon thereafter we had a party
press and it was brutal and the press
would at least be transparent they would
identify with a political party with a
candidate with a cause and Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams would really
Duke it out some of the people in the
press were actually on the payroll of a
political party and so forth but they
were all open about it again it was very
very ugly then you move into a period
and that and that lasted from about 1782
to the Civil War let's jump forward to
the early part of the last century the
progressive movement
well they devoured much of our
government their ideology did it does
today they devoured the so called media
at the time too they wanted to
professionalize it they wanted standards
they said we need to be more objective
but they said we need that you know we
need to have a handful of elites a
handful of people who understand the
country understand the world through
which all of this will be laundered
which is the way they view government -
the people are stupid that people are
plebs they're too busy or they're too
ignorant let us tell them what to think
today's media that's their heritage but
they've taken it a step further
they're social activists that's what
they are they're being taught this in
journalism school it's not enough to
report the facts it's not enough to be
objective they argue whatever that means
we have to push an agenda some of them
are out of the closet and they admit
that we need to push the liberal or
progressive agenda some of them when you
when you challenge them they say you're
attacking freedom of the press and they
pretend that they're still objective
when they're not survey after survey
study after study shows half of the
country the vast majority Republicans
the vast majority of people who lean
conservative or are conservative do not
trust the media and there's a reason for
it another half do Democrats and
liberals think the media is pretty darn
good so when you lose the trust of half
the country you're not doing your job
and they're not doing their job they
play to an itch even the word objective
is debated do we need objective in terms
of the of the thinking of the
journalists do we mean objective in
terms of the process so they pretty much
have surrendered that you know a couple
months ago Chuck Todd I'll meet the
press he declared that manmade climate
change is a fact and we're not gonna
allow deniers we're not gonna allow
deniers on Meet the Press
he's more than the host to Meet the
Press he's the chief political guru for
the entire NBC network mark you see
you've seen they have a whole so-called
news channel that's a conspiracy channel
MSNBC it's sort of like Roswell New
Mexico every night over there but this
is an enormous disservice to the
American people Chuck Todd doesn't know
the first thing about climate change or
so called climate sure you have
physicists you have PhDs climatologist
meteorologists not just hundreds of them
thousands of them who debate manmade
climate change debate its effect debate
of exists and he has declared we're not
gonna allow that on my show so that
demonstrates to you he's pushing an
agenda this whole Russia collusion thing
what I write about in the book also Sean
is the notion of news versus propaganda
versus pseudo events the president of
the United States is really on to
something when he talks about fake news
there was a brilliant historian
University of Chicago Daniel Boorstin
who became head of the library Congress
he wrote a book on pseudo events and he
was talking about the news among other
things they create their own reality by
how they choose events how they create
events how journalists promote
themselves through drama you see it with
Jim Acosta who creates conditions where
the focus is on him and not the news
this is an enormous disservice to the
American people pseudo news Russia
collusion with the Trump campaign we had
two and a half years of pseudo as the
president calls it fake news and pseudo
news requires more pseudo news so
obstruction a pseudo event it didn't
really happen but they claimed it 700
former prosecutors writing a letter all
liberals no doubt there are thousands
and thousands of former prosecutors
another pseudo event phony subpoenas
that are intended to to gather
information that had to do the American
people any good that have nothing to do
with congressional oversight pseudo
events this impeachment debate
absolutely phony another pseudo event
meanwhile there's all kinds of events
taking place in the world and in this
country that are not being covered by
news organizations there's some
exceptions but in the aggregate this is
the condition we face this is an
enormous disservice to the American
people remember this the First Amendment
belongs to the American people the Bill
of Rights belongs to the American people
the Constitution belongs to the American
people when they say Donald Trump is
like a dictator because he calls the
media or a media outlet or a media
person the enemy of the people they have
no idea what they're talking about
Donald Trump points out questions them
is harsh and his rhetoric and ought to
be and you have a cost in a few weeks is
gonna write a book and say we basically
have never seen anything like this Shawn
let me give you a little history lesson
it's in the book is that all of this is
in the book let me give you a little
history lesson this it did I just want
to tell our audience oh no this is a
very hard interview for me though but
this is honestly the amount of work
because I've been in your house when you
do your books you see them Stockholm I
mean is an entire two rooms full of
books and papers and I don't know how
you do it but keep going it's I just
want people to know how much history is
in this because I'm a nerd what can I
say well we need a lot on earth you know
you mentioned Thomas Paine think about
what he said mark and this history that
you're going through government in its
best state is but a necessary evil and
it's war state an intolerable one but
continue the media says Donald Trump is
the greatest threat or some of them do
to freedom of the press we've ever seen
that is a flat-out lie they are
historical illiterate let's start
quickly John Adams John Adams one of the
great founders and he was a great man
and a great writer about liberty and all
all things so he and his party put in
place the Alien and Sedition Act
Sedition Act is if you criticize that
president you criticize his party you
criticize the government he is the power
to imprison you and you know what he
imprisoned some journalist and he shut
down some newspapers Jefferson was
furious Jefferson was a libertarian and
he runs against Adams among other things
against the Alien and Sedition Act he
wins in a in a brutal campaign and I
won't get into all the details but he
wins and he gets rid of the Sedition Act
and the media attack him and brutalize
him and so what that is the party press
the party press that supported Adams and
Hamilton and his bar in that party would
viciously attack him and he would still
say I'm not going to touch it
Abraham Lincoln during the Civil War
through his secretary war Stan
shut down approximately 300 newspapers
and imprisoned a slew of journalists
among others among others because they
felt they needed to whatever your
argument is they felt they needed to
because of this civil war Woodrow Wilson
one of the great progressive
intellectuals who became president the
United States one was by accident he
went further he put a new Sedition Act
in place in 1918 and an extension of our
the Espionage Act we're familiar with
that and what he and his party did is
they went after journalists they
disagreed with they went after political
opponents they disagreed when they put
him in jail he also put in place an
extensive censorship campaign in an
extensive government propaganda campaign
the great progressive Franklin Roosevelt
turned the IRS on newspapers he
disagreed with the owner The Enquirer
was investigated by the IRS at his
direction
Gannett was in was investigated at the
direction of Eleanor Roosevelt so they
would use the IRS Kennedy did to Barack
Obama this is recent history the FBI the
Department of Justice went after the New
York Times James James Rosen went after
James Rosen of this network when after
20 reporters at The Associated Press
Barack Obama Donald Trump hasn't done
any of these things and to call him the
greatest strength of the press is an
absolute outrage
this is just a primer this is this is
all in this book the history is
phenomenal
it's they even bring up in presidential
elections charges of big bigamy and
dueling and you show this history and
it's fascinating to see how it has
evolved but I also want to bring it into
current a and I do believe the
president's branding of fake news will
forever be tattooed in their foreheads
because of how low they have sunk the
books phenomenal on freedom of the press
we continue with the great one Mark
Levin when we come back we'll discuss
the media's unhinge coverage of the
Russia probe and their meltdown the
night Donald Trump was elected as a
special edition of Hannity continues